[Music]
contact tracing is underway this morning
for more than 200 people who may have
been exposed to the coronavirus at a new
jersey fundraiser
for president trump last week the
president traveled to the fundraiser
despite the white house knowing
before he left washington that a closed
aide had tested positive for the virus
a republican official tells cbs news
that the site was professionally cleaned
and sanitized
but it is still unclear how many guests
received a coronavirus test before the
event
new jersey's democratic governor phil
murphy joins us now governor murphy good
morning to you
i know you wish the president a speedy
recovery we wish the president a speedy
recovery
but we also hope for the continued
health and welfare of the people of new
jersey and that's where i want to begin
i'm curious what was your reaction when
you learned the president traveled to
your state
after learning that his close aide had
tested positive and what are your
biggest concerns now
good to be with you tony and i
underscore that we wish the president
and the first lady anybody who's been
infected a speedy recovery
that's very frustrating there's no other
way to put it
um we have paid an enormous price in new
jersey
uh with covid we've lost over 14 000
people
we've gotten things largely under
control but we're dealing with our own
spikes inside of our
four walls and to have a group
as they say the virus doesn't care who
you are new jersey doesn't care who you
are a group of folks from out of state
coming in knowingly having been exposed
to someone who's coveted positive
is really really frustrating it's
complicated we started the contact
tracing immediately
we ultimately got a list of the
attendees by mid-afternoon on friday
uh by the way it's a group of folks who
are nationally based not just
in new jersey we've got staff members of
the club
that we're contact tracing with here
we've done everything and we continue to
do everything we can we need more out of
the federal side of this
so governor but it's extremely
frustrating governor murphy uh
i also know it was frustrating that that
initial list of attendees did not
include phone numbers or addresses so it
was difficult to contact them
now that you are attempting to contact
them have you found any evidence of a
coveted spread
to the best of my knowledge no i was
just down with our health commissioner
this morning but there's a big but here
uh and you're you had a discussion just
prior to my coming on here
that addressed this it could be days uh
this
this virus takes a number of days to
incubate
uh so the notion of hey i just i got a
test after i heard this
and it came back negative so i could go
on my merry way that's not how this
works
anybody who was associated with that
fundraiser regardless of where they live
have got to take themselves off the
field you self-quarantine
first and foremost then after sort of
five to seven
days you get a test you still self
quarantine but you probably get another
test
but but you gotta take yourself off the
field exactly right governor murphy were
you given a heads up that there had been
an
issue in your state or did you hear
about it on the news like many of us did
yeah gail i did not get a heads up
unfortunately do you think you should
have gotten a heads up under the
circumstances
i think gail the thing that should have
happened is nobody should have come to
new jersey
that that trip should have been canceled
uh we're all doing
meetings virtually i'm doing fundraisers
we're all doing things that
allow us to have some amount of virtual
intimacy
that's what should have been done here
the the trip itself
was the wrong decision at every level
you know what i keep hearing that
we all wish the president and the first
lady a speedy recovery that's absolutely
true but i'm also hearing
people are angry that they're even put
in this position do you think the anger
is justified
and that maybe this will be a wake-up
call for even the president of the
united states
i think yes to both i think people have
a right to be upset and angry
uh particularly folks who have been
doing
all the right things every step of the
way
and secondly i hope it's a wake-up call
uh
and by the way we talk about this
chapter it's a law it's now a long book
with lots of chapters
of indoor behavior no face coverings
uh no social distancing that it can't go
on i hope to god
finally this gets through to everybody
uh no matter where you live no matter
what your party
that you've got to do the right thing
governor you said that this event should
not have happened
i'm curious the state has very strict
guidelines for who should come
what gatherings are okay i know as of
friday you were investigating whether
any social
distancing guidelines had been violated
by the president or his party
is that investigation ongoing what are
the findings
yes that would not come from my office
that would be a law enforcement matter
the attorney general
uh and and i there's a lot of attention
right now on the event i'll leave it at
that
uh part of this apparently was indoors
um
and so that's we all know the virus is a
lot more lethal
inside than it is outside um
but but this this entire uh event and
everything associated with it is
troubling
and it is being followed up on as best
we can and as aggressively as we can
here in new jersey i know you've been in
contact with your predecessor chris
christie who was also diagno
diagnosed with cobot what can you tell
us about how he's doing without breaking
any confidence
that the two of you share yeah we wish
the governor
and his first lady nothing but a speedy
recovery
the governor and i exchanged notes over
the weekend he knows we're here for him
beyond that i don't have any insights
it's been widely reported that he
as a precautionary matter checked
himself in to a hospital and and he is
in our prayers
uh as well all right governor murphy
thank you very much we appreciate you
being with us today
thank you tony thank you gail thank you